okay the prom i'm very excited because
it uh didn't drop yet on uh netflix
but i was told that because you were
coming on the program
i could get a sneak peek at it so i got
a special code
and uh watched it last night and it's
fantastic it's beautifully done
all of you are of course uh terrific and
then i'm looking at it and i'm thinking
okay i'm talking to andrew reynolds
tomorrow and you have scenes a lot of
scenes with meryl
streep what's i mean how do you not
step outside your body when you're
performing with meryl streep were you
able to hold it together were you a
professional
no no no
definitely not professional no it didn't
take long i mean we had a really sort of
traditional
rehearsal process so we had about five
weeks in a studio where we all got
together and all learned all the
choreography and all that so that's a
very leveling
situation that everyone's coming in on
the same page we're all learning
together um so that felt really good but
then once we started
filming um yeah my wheels came off
pretty quick
and i was asking a lot of uh very direct
questions about she devil and uh
you know death becomes her and i you
would think that you would probably ask
about like
sophie's choice um but i kept throwing
her curveballs
right i would get in there with like
roseanne barr questions
yeah you figured everybody's asking her
about sophie's choice or kramer vs
streamer
i'm gonna get in there with she devil
yep she devil
death becomes her like i had a lot a lot
a lot of questions for her
and i will say she was extremely patient
and very um very cool about nicole
kidman also was like
very understanding about me losing my
mind
nicole actually after like a you know a
month of working with her i was like
moulin rouge is one of my favorite
movies and i've seen it probably more
times than
any movie and which is odd because it's
very dark
um but i love it and it's comforting to
me that you know she dies of consumption
i don't know what that says about me but
um i just love that movie
and she was gracious enough to reenact
her death scene
from that film like while we were in
between takes and we were standing
together like waiting to go you know do
this thing and
and she did it she did her full death i
hate to break it to you but she also
does it on cameo
for yeah and you know what it's pretty
cheap
it cost me eighty dollars and nicole
well that is
if nicole kidman was on cameo can you
imagine
i love the idea of huge stars on cameo
and they're in their bathroom with the
crappy
shower curtain behind them and they're
recreating you know de niro's doing
you talking to me you talking to me and
he's doing it and then you pay a hundred
and ten dollars
yeah and you could get that scene done
for you and be like yeah
happy birthday mitch and happy birthday
mitch you looking at me